لقد كانت بالتأكيد صفعة على الوجه
مع الأخطبوط، إنه أمر مضحك
ولا أعتقد أنه إذا لم يتم التقاطه
بالكاميرا فلن يصدقك أحد أبدًا، لقد
كنا في الواقع نمارس رياضة التجديف بالكاياك في البحر
وذهبنا إلى إحدى مدنتي المفضلة
وإيوتا  وهي كايكودا وهي مشهورة جدًا
بالحياة البحرية والحيتان والفقمات والدلافين،
كل ذلك بهدف مشاهدة
الأختام على الصخور وحدث أن
رأينا إحدى الفقمات كانت في الماء
تقاتل أخطبوطًا وحرفيًا،
ذهب القتال تحت الماء و  ساد الهدوء وكنا
ننظر
حولنا ولم نكن نعرف إلى أين يحدث ما كان
يحدث ثم جاءت الظلال
أسفل قوارب الكاياك وأعتقد أن
الأخطبوط حاول السباحة بعيدًا
وطارده ولا أعرف ما كان
يحدث ولكن  كان صديقي تايو في
المقدمة يحمل كاميرا GoPro واستدار
في الوقت المناسب عندما
ظهر الختم على السطح وهو يقاتل الأخطبوط وصادف أن
وجهي كان في
المكان الصحيح أو المكان الخطأ في
الوقت المناسب أو المكان الصحيح  في
الوقت الخطأ، لست متأكدًا تمامًا من
أنه لم يؤلمني ولكن كان الأمر غريبًا جدًا، لقد
كان شعورًا مثل منشفة مبللة على
الوجه ولكن أقسم أنني شعرت بكل
الأشياء الصغيرة التي تمر
عبر وجهي ومن ثم عندما تشاهد
الفيديو كان ردود أفعالي نوعًا ما، أوه، ما
حدث للتو
[موسيقى]
كان ذلك منذ فترة طويلة ولكن
لا يزال موجودًا، أعتقد أن أعظم
شيء حدث من هذا هو أنه
وضع كايكولدا على الخريطة بشكل عام، لقد كان
في الواقع أمرًا إيجابيًا حقًا  تجربة
تحت الماء